now if you have stiffness always consider the
liver okay the liver if it's not working right
will completely make your joints almost you
like you feel like you have arthritis okay
and let's talk about why that is now the number
one point is you might have something called
coleostasis okay coleostasis what
does that mean it means that your
bile is being backed up it's not flowing through
the pipes through the tubes they're called
there's ducts okay like the bile ducts and
bile is supposed to flow freely through there
but sometimes it gets thick and so you have
this combination of too much cholesterol and
not enough bile and it's kind of just it gets all
jammed up and it backs up and it creates a lot of
inflammation to the body now the bile is produced
by the liver and it should drain through the ducts
and be stored in the gallbladder and if there's
a problem with these ducts boy you're going to
have pain and primarily on the right side of
your body actually you're going to be stiff
and you're going to pain if you don't have
enough bile also you're not going to absorb
and utilize vitamin d which is a very powerful
anti-inflammatory right off the bat so without
vitamin d you're going to feel kind of
stiff you're going to have back pain too
all right also the other fat cyber vitamins are
not going to be available to you like vitamin k2
which is also responsible of transporting
calcium from the blood into the bone
so it doesn't deposit in your arteries and your
joints okay so it keeps calcium in the right place
so you might be deficient in k2 not because you're
not consuming is because you don't have the bile
and also vitamin e that's
another fat soluble vitamin
and without vitamin e you can't counter all the
free radical damage that goes on in the body
with your average diet also you're not going to be
able to absorb omega-3 fatty acids and omega-3 are
the anti-inflammatory fatty acids okay so right
there you can see that not having this bile flow
that well you can have problems with all of these
right here all right so what's the solution just
start taking purified bile salts okay i put
a link down below of what i would recommend
and you would just take this on an empty stomach
take one in the morning and then take one in the
afternoon and you can even take like two at a time
and so that way you're taking four and that should
open the ducts up and if this is the problem you
should feel better immediately like within like an
hour now parallel to this to correct this problem
you need to get on something called healthy keto
and intermittent fasting okay because that will
ultimately help your liver so then you can make
bile cor and have it flow correctly through the
system healthy keto and intermittent fasting
greatly improves a fatty liver and other problems
with the liver okay so i put a link down below of
the program if you're not familiar with it
all right number two eliminate the omega-6
fatty acids if you go out to dinner a lot
or you eat junk foods you're consuming a
lot of omega-6 fatty acids and that
can be the reason why you are stiff
this is why when people go out to dinner they
always stick these like soy oil corn oil in the
food and then you feel stiff and you don't know
why that's why number three start doing fasting
fasting is one of the most powerful things to
repair a damaged liver and if the liver is doing
better your stiffness and joints will always do
better and so if you learn about fasting you're
going to learn about something called autophagy
which is the recycling of damaged proteins
like scar tissue in your liver and so to clean
that up is going to give you more liver function
and less stiffness and pain and this is a very
important point let's say it's not your liver you
just have osteoarthritis which is different than
the autoimmune disease called rheumatoid arthritis
osteoarthritis is mainly from old injuries
okay um and it's a situation where your joints
are wearing out because there's some imbalance
in the mechanics of your joints so it's wearing
more on one side than the other because there's
not symmetry because your body is in this
guarding mode because of an old injury because
of compensation okay i had a lot of that going on
here's what you need to know
you cannot have osteoarthritis
if there's a motion in that joint correct
symmetrical motion you can't have that arthritis
so the secret is to keep that joint
moving and so there's a very very great
technique that i stumbled on that i'm going to
recommend i don't teach it myself but you can find
someone in your area that teaches it you can get
this done remotely like a one-on-one type coaching
there's books on it there's videos on it but
it's a great technique to keep your joints
balanced and keep your joints from turning
arthritic and it's called the august q method okay
so it's and i wrote down the pronunciation because
it's a little hard to pronounce ah goss q okay so
i put a link down below on their website i'm not
affiliated with them but i think it's a very valid
amazing technique for those people who have pain
chronic pain bad posture etc all right guys thanks
for watching this video stay tuned for the next
one hey before you go real quick i have a course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course i want you to take it and
here's why here's you here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today